[Music]
a man who lost both legs in a DUI crash
sharing his story tonight as he
continues his long road to recovery he
really he really wants to remind people
what can happen if they choose to drive
impaired Sasha loft is joining us in
studio tonight with a story you'll only
see on ape Sasha Denise and Brian the
man I spoke with tonight has been
through hell but he's choosing to share
his story to push for change he hopes
what he's been through will encourage
others to think differently
I was screaming out why me you know why
why does something like this have to
happen
Riley McGowan recalls the moment his
world was changed forever I heard a
screech and a bang and I look up the 23
year old was working in the median here
on Casino Center near the U.S 95.
when he says a drunk driver jumped the
curb slammed into his work truck and ran
him over I remember trying to crawl away
now nearly two months and 10 surgeries
later Riley has lost both his legs and
he's doing his best to navigate this new
normal
he never could have imagined we never
know what's going to come up after this
or because of this it's been anything
but easy but Riley hopes by sharing his
story he can convince at least one
person to think twice before getting
behind the wheel impaired whether it be
them getting in an accident
or them causing an accident and harming
somebody else and going away for life
you know
there's going to be consequences of your
actions as he focuses on starting again
grateful for this second chance because
you never know when your last second is
going to be
Riley's family has started a GoFundMe to
help with medical expenses now as for
the driver who police say hit him she
pled guilty to a felony charge of
driving Under the Influence resulting in
substantial bodily harm she also has two
prior DUI charges and is due in court
for sentencing on September 29